département des yvelines vous le savez
jusqu'à présent était plutôt ancré à
droite françois fillon est arrivé en
deuxième position 13 mille voix le
sépare des manuels macron les affaires
semblent avoir un peu pesé dans le choix
des électeurs
mais ce soutien aux représentants des
républicains du département ne suffit
donc pas à le qualifier au second tour
et coûté suzanne blanc et lui à montigny
le bretonneux c'est l'une des
responsables de campagne dans les
yvelines elle était très déçue hier soir
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire un
sentiment de tristesse forcément quand
on s'est battu pendant tant de mois
voire tant d'années bien évidemment on
ne peut être que triste déçu
voilà mais c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
c'est c'est la loi de c'est la loi du
suffrage universel
les français se sont prononcés derrière
cette deuxième place dans le département
pour françois fillon il ya de grandes
différences au niveau des différentes
communes ainsi l encours françois fillon
totalise 18,77 % des voix derrière
emmanuel macron et jean luc mélenchon
écouter le maire de la commune
il faut que monsieur mac on sorte de
cette image de communication et qui nous
disent vraiment avec qui il veut
gouverner quelles sont ses engagements
économiques quelle majorité quelle
premier ministre et et si on tombe
d'accord sur un minimum de règles qu'il
remet notre pays qui relancent
l'économie l'investissement productif
les emplois le niveau de vie la
protection des retraites et du modèle
social français
oui on sera attentif et on sera positif
ça va de soi si monsieur macron partage
ce type de projet et souhaitent une
majorité avec des gens sérieux
voilà moi je serais je serai de bonne
volonté autres communes montigny le
bretonneux françois fillon et est
deuxième avec presque 20 % des suffrages
emmanuel macron lui dépasser les 35%
là aussi réaction du maire par ailleurs
président de saint quentin en yvelines
michel jau j ai résiste bien mais vous
savez là
il n'y a pas de résister aux pas résisté
soit on est présent au second tour soit
on ne l'est pas je regrette qu'ils
doivent à présent au second tour parce
qu'effectivement les affaires sont venus
plomber un petit peu tout et cette
campagne et c'est vrai que bon il ne
faisait pas parti lui de l'élite de la
presse donc il n'a pas de forcément été
bien encadrés et soutenus par enfin il
n'y a pas eu vraiment de vraie campagne
on notera en revanche qu'à rambouillet
françois fillon est en tête avec plus de
28% en tête également à versailles avec
42 99% des suffrages les ténors
politiques du département ont rapidement
appelé à voter emmanuel macron second
tour de gérard larcher président du
sénat à valérie pécresse présidente de
la région ou encore par un pierre bédier
le président du département des yvelines
aujourd'hui les républicains doivent se
réorganiser et plutôt vite stéphane
mention puisqu'il ya ce troisième tour
les élections législatives est ce que
c'est possible que pour une formation
politique de se réorganiser même si
c'est inédit que ni ps ni les
républicains c'est compliqué et c'est
compliqué parce que au regard notamment
les leurs aujourd'hui banon et puis on
regarde l'inversion du calendrier entre
élections présidentielle et législatives
on sait que ce sont désormais les
présidentielles qui font oeuvre de
dynamique pour les législatives
et c'est ce qui ad'ailleurs été voulue
au regard de la révision
constitutionnelle donc très compliqué
pour les républicains mais encore plus
compliqué pour les socialistes tout ce
qui nous reste
on va évoquer le cas des socialistes
juste concernant les républicains un
dernier mot sur la ligne de conduite des
différents ténors justement parce que
j'en ferais avec poisson l'ancien
candidat à la primaire député des
yvelines président du parti chrétien
démocrate lui n'entend pas glissé un
bulletin macron dans l'urne à écouter
jean marie le pen n'est pas bon pour le
pays et que c'est notre sentiment celui
même on n'est pas meilleurs pour qu'il
faut il faut y ont tout fait fort
grâce à une
forte poussée lors des élections
législatives que nous voyons en
situation de faire valoir notre projet
politique et républicains et leurs
alliés une très grande timidité pour ne
pas dire une suite de renoncement qui
nous voient un reproche très peur de la
part des transferts ça veut dire que si
nous faisons l'analyse et il faudra la
faire à froid de ce qui s'est passé hier
nous devons en tirer toutes les
conséquences en matière de fidélité à
notre propre faute de valeur parce que
c'est ça que les français attendent de
nous